are you ready witches
I'm your hi hostess Liana Galera and
this is the witches council et's
spellbinding show that's all about the
Chili Adventures of Sabrina today I'm
about to brew up some finale spoilers
and spill exclusive details from Brina
herself Kiernan Shipka about that
shocking final episode it's been a wild
ride it's been a crazy character to play
if you have not watched the full season
of Sabrina just yet go sign your name of
the book of the beast and then come back
here when you're ready to embrace your
full powers for everyone else let's
conjure up some fun now in episode 10
aka the chilling season one finale
Sabrina finally gives herself over to
Satan and signs her name in the book of
the Beast in order to save the town of
Greendale from impending doom with her
newfound powers at full force
Sabrina follows miss Ward wells dark
guidance and summons Hellfire to burn
the Greendale 13
not only did Sabrina save her town full
of loved ones she also walked away from
that spell sporting and I see new look
and I loved it we got to talk about that
final scene girl first of all your hair
talked to me about the evolution of the
hair and hotend the stylistic choices
behind that I mean it was that was you
know the last thing we we shot before we
went on a little week hiatus and no one
put that wig on faster that night I get
one last kiss when we see them at the
very end things are not as lovey-dovey
as when they started yeah it's kind of
sad isn't it because you always want
Harvey and Sabrina to be getting
together that iconic couple but because
Harvey comes from a long line of witch
hunters he doesn't take to the magic
very easily and that that eventually
kind of holds them apart what was your
reaction when Sabrina told Harvey that
she was a witch and it actually sucked
that last time honestly I was thinking
like if someone actually told you in
real life that they're a witch like
that's kind of unbelievable news so
there was a lot of things going in my
head at that moment and then obviously
we need to seem like six or seven times
you try to keep it fresh but I know that
the fans are going to absolutely love
the scene with Harvey and Sabrina in the
back of the pickup truck will you stay
with me
oh my no those are my favorite moments
especially with someone like your name
who's obviously so easy to work with but
also she's a really sweet person it
scared in like how can you not you know
feel some way towards her as we move
into season two what can you tease about
Harvey and Serena's relationship well
now she's she's not gonna be going to
Baxter high quite as frequently so
Harvey won't be able to see her as much
changed your hair yeah what do you think
of the hair oh I actually really like it
yeah I like it a lot I think it's super
cool yeah I think it looks good on Kenny
- well I'm glad Ross likes it because
Sabrina showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa told me that Sabrina's
new hairstyle which is a nod to the
Sabrina graphic novels is definitely
gonna stick around in season two Roberta
also told me that will explore more of
Sabrina's wicked darker side next season
hmm well now that breena's powers have
been elevated and she's walking like a
badass into the next bewitching chapter
here's what Kiernan said about her
season one evolution and what we can
expect from season two was amazing
because I feel like there's moments in
the first couple episodes that really
pay off in the last couple episodes that
I was personally so excited to play out
because it just kind of it all rocked up
really in a wonderful way it's been a
wild ride it's been a crazy character to
play it's so amazing so fun and just to
play someone that really does have an
arc and growth is just amazing as Brina
leaves season 1 she's a super powerful
witch looking youichi's about season 2
it gets even crazier it gets even
crazier and darker even darker than
season 1 sign me up
in fact guess what which is I'm gonna be
hopping on my broomstick and flying over
to Vancouver to visit the season 2 set
of the chilling Adventures of Sabrina so
enchant me with your biggest questions
for season 2 what would you like to see
Sabrina tackle next which character do
you think needs more screen time in
season 2 and are you glad that Brina
ditched the blonde and is rockin a
white-hot look tell me in the comments
and if you enjoyed this episode of
witches council please give this video a
like and hit subscribe so you can summon
more episodes to your screens thanks for
watching witches and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]